so those people in Mass are uh are in
these in are demanding vaccine mandates
cheering for it
and we got we got so much on this stuff
I'm saying this is why we started with
the New Hampshire seceding from the
union thing because I'm like yo this is
all just gonna fall apart you ready for
this here you go Libby you live in New
York City right I do de Blasio rolls out
covet booster shot plan utilizing all
NYC vaccination sites we're ready so
it's only a matter of time until you're
the person at the restaurant with them
saying do you have proof of vaccination
and you show them and they'll go this
only has two on it right yeah and you're
gonna be like but I'm vaccinated yeah
but now we're doing boosters yeah I know
to be fair that's what's the the current
mandate is for at least one shot right
so it's going which is funny isn't it
New York New Orleans San Francisco and
LA
the funny thing is uh and then all of
California probably they're saying it's
a vaccine mandate
but you don't have to be fully
vaccinated
so my my question there is is one shot
enough it's just because it's about
compliance it's only about compliance
yeah you can you can a vaccine card is
not a negative covid test you can you
could actually have a vaccine card have
been vaccinated contract covid and then
go to this restaurant show them your
vaccine card and sit down but yeah you
see the story about that lady the thing
with the antibodies right so if you've
had covid and you have a natural
immunity that doesn't count which is
absurd yeah right that's just absurd and
for big events I was just at a music
festival in Greenwich and basically you
know unvaccinated people were required
for a test to have a test and vaccinated
were not required to have a test I mean
why wouldn't everybody be required to
have a test because everybody can spread
it so like that is a core hypocrisy
everyone should have to get tested if
everyone is still spreading it right how
is that controversial did you see that
story about the woman who was vaccinated
but got coveted and died from it and in
their obituary they were like she was
vaccinated but was infected by someone
who chose not to be and it's like well
you don't know that like Breakthrough
cases are rare but they happen she got
one maybe she got it from somebody who
also had a breakthrough case just making
that up but this is the craziest thing
when they say stuff like we must protect
the vaccinated from the unvaccinated and
I'm like I don't understand what that
means but so the response from many of
these people on the left has been we're
saying that the unvaccinated are loading
up hospital beds and congesting you you
know the hospitals and I was like oh so
we should protect the fit from the fat
oh so fat people should get the boot
from from the hospital for triage for
only the healthy people well and of
course that was mayor Michael
Bloomberg's thing when he was the mayor
of New York he had he wanted a uh I
think he passed it there was like an
extra tax on big gulps yes that's right
yeah I don't know if that passed I know
he asked and then it got repealed a year
later yeah yeah I know he was there for
a minute he's the guy who famously said
tax the poor unironically literally said
poor people are too stupid to know what
to buy so if we take their money from
them and buy it for them they'll be
better off
yeah I don't see how this country stays
I'm having a bit of a problem when
they're like the vaccinated people are
can maybe contracted from the
unvaccinated but it's also from what
I've learned in the animal population so
technically someone could contract it
from an animal like a dog I don't I
don't know about that we talked about it
before and people have mentioned animal
what's called animal uh Reservoir yes
yeah so that coved can be transferred
and it can be in cats and stuff but I
know it can be in bats but I think I
think there was something that was a
study or whatever or an article that
said when it does transfer to animals it
doesn't transfer back but they said
people got it from a bat right
if that's the case then there you go and
and so that's the art and there's
Chinese studies that it's in ice cream
like
you keep bringing that up I know because
they did one article about it and where
did it go
the food supply people need to
understand that Ian eats a lot of ice
not anymore
count me out what's that well that's why
the origin does matter in an uncensored
public debate about everything related
to this because that's what science is
science is a public debate that has
access to the full spectrum of
information so for anyone who says that
they defend science but they're all
about getting rid of misinformation well
actually uh you're not really helping
the scientific process to play out well
that's the meme it's like we believe in
you know all of the scientists agree and
then a scientist goes actually I have
something to say and they go banned from
social media all of the scientists agree
so you got a bunch of doctors that have
been talking about alternative therapies
and stuff but they get banned from every
every platform so it's like when they
say a doc this is what I love I keep
telling people like go see go see a
doctor you trust don't just take it from
celebrities or TV doctors and it was
really funny when leftists started
attacking me for that and I'm like why
are you mad at me and they're like
you're just scaring people it's safe
they should go to the parking lot at the
7-Eleven and get their vaccine from the
you know the pop-ups that they do and I
was like they should talk to their
doctor first and then go to the pop-up
and they're like no and you know why
because some doctors might give you
better more personalized advice and
oppose their political medical opinions
well these are the same people who
definitely don't want women to see
ultrasounds before they go through with
abortions they really don't want women
to see that oh yeah so they oppose those
laws and then you know because if you
see an ultrasound I was pregnant one
time and you see the ultrasound and it's
crazy you're like oh my God that's my
baby
that's what Texas does life Texas
requires that they really complain about
that stuff like forcing you to see an
ultrasound it's like forcing you to see
the life inside your body how strange oh
crazy what are you gonna do when the
booster happens in New York oh I'm not I
don't think I'm getting get a booster
because there's been a bunch of studies
and you don't need it I don't have any
interest in getting it
um but then what do you do what happens
when they're like fully vaccinated now
means booster shots every five months I
don't know you know I gotta say you can
leave I'm at like I'm sort of at a total
loss I keep uh
I keep looking for other places to live
you know what it is it's interesting I
don't have anything tying me to New York
I used to have a lot of things tying me
to New York like lots and lots of things
and now I have like there's no reason
for me to be there uh there's also no
reason for me to be anywhere else I
basically have no reason to be anywhere
at all there is a reason there but there
is a reason there's a reason to be
somewhere else but which other else
which else well hold on which else
should I be in Montana that works
Montana you're closer to Canada and
those post-millennial peeps right yeah
they're in Vancouver right no they're in
they're in Quebec oh really New
Hampshire I speak French not really
there's a big super volcano in mind well
oh really yeah oh oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
but uh uh Andy knows up in Portland
uh Bozeman yeah that's a college town
I'm sure it's very blue yeah those are
options I will put them on the map you
should see my map it's ridiculous I can
go here I could go there yeah I mean the
other thing too that I uh I've only ever
lived in the Northeast right like I've
lived in
I've never lived in Maine Maine's great
blueberry is kind of nice I actually
went up to Maine with Bill one time on
vacation the water is freezing well sure
yeah and they have black flies those big
things they bite you they have green
ones in New Jersey you know what they do
they they when they bite you it's not
really quite a bite at first it's like
these little scissors scissors jaws and
they slice away at your skin and then
they bury their face inside and suck
your blood out that way that's why the
bite hurts so much oh yeah because it's
not like the little needle it's like
there's up in there wow those are like
those black mosquitoes they look
engineered have you ever seen one of
those up close they look like robots or
the ones
like the the patterns on them oh I
haven't seen them they're little stripy
things those things yeah yeah I think
that's what they're terrible they're
like leopard mosquitoes if you if you're
Dr Seuss mosquitoes if you go to Maine
right you're in the Northeast and you
can get a big plot or hey wait a minute
New Hampshire hey New Hampshire do you
know I have a lot of family there there
you go look at that so you got reason to
leave New York and reason to be in New
Hampshire perhaps and you can do
whatever you want for the most part you
can have chickens
we're big fans yeah
has there been a succession
has there been any form of an actual
secession in
common you know memory or like anywhere
anywhere part of Idaho is trying or part
of Oregon is trying to yeah to Idaho
when did the whole Sudanese thing happen
with Sudan and South Sudan that's
probably I mean it was a while ago yeah
so probably not in our lifetime unless
look I'll be honest
I'm sure a lot of people are gonna make
oh yeah look at these countries and look
at that there's a bunch of different
people across the United States trying
to succeeded Jefferson you've got a
district in Colorado trying to join
Wyoming the Czech Republic in Slovakia
they split up oh yeah that's right we
had all kinds of Eastern block stuff
that was what 90 oh yeah 92 93 the
Soviet Union collapsed okay we had all
of those all of those Baltic states but
it's not the same thing no like I guess
it is I guess once they just break apart
the union no longer exists well it's
it's definitely different the United
States is different it it's different
worldwide right when the U.S
um the U.S is the beacon of Freedom it's
all of these things that we American
exceptionalists say that it is and it's
these things in part because we say it
is and it's these things in part because
of our history when the U.S if the U.S
crumbles if the U.S loses freedom and
liberty then the world loses those
things it's not just us it's our entire
world I just want people to realize
something I want to imagine something I
mean Australia is not a free place no
right we we know that the people the the
you know I love to cite the the poll on
economics that Democrats think the
economy is doing fairly well but
independent Republicans think it's doing
fairly bad which is objectively true
especially with the latest like
inflation numbers and and all that stuff
and the forecasting down to the GDP and
things like that which Drexel says is
still pretty good but anyway I digress
I want you to imagine these people who
live in California who voted for Gavin
Newsom
they adamantly believe you are in a
death cult and it's funny because you'll
see it on Reddit you'll see it on
Twitter they say these people are in a
death cult and you're like it's really
weird how
in this political faction we can have
liberals moderate centrists
conservatives religious folk all having
discussions and debates on a variety of
issues
all disagreeing but agreeing on Liberty
and principle and then being told
they're an occult and then you have the
completely homogeneous
faction on the left believing they're
not in the cult but they just believe
whatever they're told on TV my favorite
is when you go to like R Politics on
Reddit and there will be a headline
that's an outright lie and if you
actually click the article you'll see
it's not true but all of the comments
are like with Mark and this is true so I
want you to imagine those kind of those
people
then I want you to imagine an actual
conflict breaking out and they're
telling themselves and their friends and
their families the dangerous Trump death
cultists are trying to take this country
and we have to stop them the
Insurrection all of that stuff which
they genuinely believe
yeah they're gonna fight they're gonna
fight believing that they're right and
then people like us are going to be
sitting here being like yo a bunch of
crazy people are trying to push crazy
nonsensical things on everyone else the
point I'm trying to make is
there is no remedying The Divide it's
impossible
it's not it's not possible I mean that's
that's an extreme statement it might be
possible it might be possible I'm
thinking about about Hitler abusing the
media to drive people crazy and and
radicalize people and now the media has
driven people crazy as radicalizing
people but there's no Hitler there's no
there's no cult leader they did away
they don't need it anymore for somehow
they don't they didn't need a cult
leader thanks for checking out this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast if you want
to see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time